that bicyclist fighting for his life and
police still haven't arrested the driver
now this all happened near the
intersection of Saint Rose and Maryland
Parkway on Sunday which was the 11th a
date with significance for the victim
Mark bobus Ryan Matthey joins us live
there now with why investigators are
having a tough time with this case Ryan
yeah guys the vobis family continues to
Grapple with that green a driver hitting
the 53 year old man and leaving him on
the side of the road and to make all
matters worse this crash happened on a
day of remembrance that hits a bit too
close to home for this family
know what to do or just wanted to go to
UMC it just was so
I couldn't think straight Jennifer
volbis were counting the phone call that
her husband 53 year old Mark vobas was
involved in a hidden run about 8 30 I
received a call from the University
Medical Center saying that they found
him someone found him unresponsive on
the side of the road Henderson Police
say a driver hit vobus from behind
throwing him to the ground destroying
his bike before driving off it feels
unjust it feels
described as a man with a passion for
helping others the date of the crime all
too coincidental vobas was a first
responder in New York City on September
11 2001. he was um on the streets of
Manhattan he was protecting the streets
and helping people and providing first
aid and now he lays minimally conscious
in a hospital bed with life-threatening
injuries unclear at this time he'll
recover from this is one of the few that
we haven't had any solid leads on
Henderson police officer and traffic
investigator Mark Rasmussen saying they
have no leads no Witnesses and no video
evidence why we're asking the public to
come forward and assist us with anybody
who saw anything that time and was able
to see anything related to that crash to
please come forward
now please tell me people have come
forward who responded to the scene no
one who actually saw it happen that's
just part of what's making this case so
difficult to solve